while Greek hero Odysseus was fighting
the Trojan Wars
Penelope was left to fend off a bunch of
unwanted admirers she promised to marry
whichever man could fire an arrow
through 12 accents confident that the
shot was impossible but Odysseus
returned and in disguise took the shot
and nailed it if the Mythbusters can
somehow repeat that success it would
prove beyond doubt that an arrow flies
straight and true here we have our 12
axes with the targets of three inches in
diameter
inspired by Odysseus's archery trick
shot so we're gonna have Byron take this
shot and see if he can get through all
12 with his longbow they say it's
impossible so good luck bro
it's a daunting prospect even Byron has
his doubts now no shootin through a
three-inch ring shouldn't be a very hard
shot and it's not shooting through three
or four I'm not a hard shot shoots
through 12 of them it's a very hard shot
doing it with a traditional bow
[Music]
[Music]
calling this a hard shot is a massive
understatement ad with a quiver full of
arrows
Byron's not about to lay down his
longbow come on you don't do that every
time he smoothly shoots the arrows
through at least the first few rings so
close but the slightest touch of shaft
or fletching on metal spells disaster
for this treacherous trickshot if your
arrow comes into contact with even so
much as a bloody crash it's going throw
it off my came in contact with four
reach steals I think the archers paradox
is what did me in anyway I couldn't do
it I tried
and while I'm thinking about it great
shot Odysseus